[Musique]
vous aimez votre registre même ancien
label la résolution prise la colline
cette épreuve regardez moi cette vie là
bas le gars
là alain potier a loupé le théâtre
mythique ceux qui ne l'aiment pas vu
d'ici n'ont jamais vu vraiment été à 36
ce n'est un petit doigt
lucienne dubost est un peu la mémoire
d'orange
regardez ce mur
c'est pas magnifique
les graveurs les voies près place et qui
dans cette ville n'est pas venu acheter
chez elle un parapluie les aujourd'hui
elle se sent un peu comme une étrangère
je ne me semble pas aussi orangeoise qu
autrefois
j'aime petit ressentiment au fond de moi
même contre ses habitants au par contre
ses habitants il faut pas tout
généraliser non contre onze on peut dire
qu'il est arrivé
n'est pas une catastrophe non humain
c'est quelque chose que
ordinaire et extraordinaire oui
d'extraordinaire mais que j'attends
d'eux mêmes par contre depuis un an je
m'attendais à ce qui est arrivé
qu'est-ce qui vous
j'ai pensé des petits comme des des
senteurs dans l'atmosphère comme tout à
l'heure nous avons senti l'odeur des
paires n'arrive à des tirs hier et puis
il ya une certaine atmosphère qui est
tombée sur la ville depuis
juin 1995
quelque chose d'extraordinaire dit
lucienne du boss le 18 juin contre toute
attente orange s'est choisi un maire
front national
[Musique]
comme il paraît loin déjà ce mois de
juin en cette belle matinée ensoleillée
doute rien ne semble pouvoir troubler la
légendaire quiétude de cette petite cité
provençale ni le concert qui se prépare
à l'autre bout de la ville ni les
travaux d'emménagement de jacques
bompard le nouveau locataire de l'hôtel
de ville
ou refaites 3,9 monsieur le maire non
non non on ne refait rien bref en gare
de tout mais par contre ses deux portes
qui valent cette porte fenêtre qui
valent très cher et qui était à
l'abandon puisque les insectes s'ils
étaient mis que laurent et on les fait
en effet rénové en effet rénové par les
fonctionnaires territoriaux qui
d'ailleurs je suis sûr sont ravis de
faire ce travail 1
ils ont fait d'ailleurs je les en
félicite un excellent boulot
c'est de travailler grave
d'entretenir le patrimoine municipal 1
ceux qui s'attendaient à une révolution
sont pour leurs frais jacques bompard a
choisi une installation en douceur
conforme à la tradition républicaine
seul le discours reste le même discours
habituel ou front national et auquel
jacques bompard donne sa touche
personnelle je suis allé une seule fois
hors d'europe c'était un congrès
d'enseignants avec des facultés
chirurgie dentaire et on est allé à
agadir et je dois dire que c'est des
étrangers avaient le même comportement
que celui que je trouve normal il n'y
aurait pas de preuves tranchée qu'en
france quand je suis allé à la khadir je
me suis tenu le plus correctement
possible encore plus correctement que ce
que je me tiens en france chez
quelquefois été houspillé par des sacs à
thiriez en particulier je me rappelle
dans le marché d'agadir où il y avait
un artisan qui avait une couleur locale
tout à fait fantastique j'ai eu envie de
le photographier s'est mis à hurler je
me suis arrêtée deux photos de jay pas
photographier et je suis partie
quasiment peu non il ne me serait pas
venu à l'idée de l'anglais il était chez
lui y'avait pas mais que je photographie
je ne photographie pas je me tais je me
dire un bon si chacun avait six petits
les étrangers en france avait cette
attitude de dit et de responsabilité de
respect des lois je crois qu'il n'y
aurait pas de problème d'être un enfant
[Musique]
vous êtes un politicien et ouais ouais
et c'est ça que je trouve une belle
ville comme sa maîtrise pas
il ne vient pas d'agadir mais d'oran en
algérie
vous reconnaissez un peu là en uruguay
un tout petit peu tu peux pas beaucoup
parce que moi je vis la nuit
sa fuite a quand même je suis pas venu
ici
quelque chose
depuis 86 ch à 4 ans m6
c'est à côté carpentras
la forme visuelle
khaled est l'un des artistes venus
chanter ce soir au théâtre antique un
concert prévu depuis des mois et ce
n'est pas l'arrivée du front national à
la tête de la municipalité qui allait le
faire changer d'avis
en plus elle a le même nom que ma ville
natale orange avec aurons
c'est vrai
d'autres comme patrick bruel ou le duo
native avait préféré annuler leur
participation
khaled lui ne se sent pas le droit de
punir les orangeois parmi lesquels il
compte beaucoup d'amis
alors tu avais je venais chez toi alors
je vais jouer chez tout mais alors rien
faire pas de problème
orange a une particularité presque une
tradition orange est volage tous les six
ans elle se donne à une équipe
municipale différentes elle fut tour à
tour radical gaulliste communistes
socialistes
ofi temps des divisions de la droite et
de celle de la gauche jacques bompard
avec seulement 87 voix d' avance en a
fait une ville front national
propulsé à la une de l'actualité des
orangeois d'abord surpris gêné n'en
finissent plus de se justifier
à gratter viseur du comptoir reportage
on est très content d'avoir le maire au
front national
j'entends tout autant des dauphins
sur la droite de la tension
moi je crois que c'est ça n'a pas de
changement les gens essayent de se
tourner en rond
qui appartient à l'état et que
l'état la france l argent du
contribuable
revenons aux étrangers et on nous faut
travailler
et lé ton à la retraite on n'a plus rien
fait pour des choses intéressantes ça
dépasse publication nationale d'accord
lalanne n'est pas l'avis de la
population estonienne
je vote de contestation perte de
confiance dans les partis traditionnels
toujours la même rengaine ici la
véritable raison du choix des orangeois
et tête ailleurs c'est un problème
philosophique c'est un problème national
c'est un problème d'éthique c'est un
problème de droits de l'homme on va
chercher telouet
des choses ou les réponses sont là mais
c'est quoi la vraie réponse mais la
vraie réponse et c'est qu'on vote ici
pour un homme c'est qu'on voit pour
quelqu'un qui travaille qui a travaillé
qui a un impact qui a un contact humain
je crois très bon qui est très sociable
qui est brillant certainement en
compagnie et les gens ils sont sensibles
ça va jusqu'à oublier qu'il ya une
éthique est très particulière
l'étiquette particulière si vous voulez
moi je crois que cette étiquette c'est
encore une chose je voudrais qu'on
laisse ces gens et ce mouvement moi je
ne suis pas forcément j'ai pas forcément
porté monsieur bompard mais ni front
national
d'ailleurs je n'avais pas votre je n'ai
pas voté front national mais
je pense qu'il faut les laisser vivre
vous comprenez c'est un parti qui depuis
des années dit il ya kayak a blessé les
gérer des cds prendre quelques
responsabilités décédé
dans le contexte qui est le leur
aujourd'hui et puis ensuite baie comeau
on peut parler des valeurs des gens des
hommes de leur action mais avant on peut
pas
décidément il est bien difficile
d'entendre une condamnation sans appel
de ce vote
tenez même les opposants les plus
farouches du nouveau maire trouve des
raisons de ne pas dramatiser et dit
personnellement que j'espérais qu'une
fois qu'ils franchissaient les portes de
sa mairie c'était c'était plus le front
national qui franchissait les portes de
la mairie poigne et je veux y croire et
c'est vrai pour me rassurer pour me
rassurer pour pour
en tant que personne et surtout pour le
développement pour le biais
pour l'instant c'est de l'extérieur que
vienne et gestes de résistance ce
concert qui se prépare baptisée la nuit
la méditerranée et qui mêle israélien
grec corse maghrébins ce concert est
devenu malgré lui le symbole de
l'opposition à jacques bompard ce
dernier ne fait d'ailleurs pas mystère
de ses goûts il promet dès l'année
prochaine un festival moins coloré
ce concert c'est aussi un baroud
d'honneur pour liberto valls le monsieur
culture de la municipalité socialiste
sortant gle farouches adversaires du
nouveau maire il n'est pas mécontent de
faire du théâtre antique une tribune
contre l'intolérance un artiste n'est
pas artiste s'il n'est pas engagé il est
décorateur de la cité et
je veux croire que le travail des
artistes que le travail des acteurs
culturels n'est pas de décor et la cité
d'être des agents de communication d
être des agents de valorisation de qui
ou de quoi mais des gens qui portent de
la parole qui porte la pensée s'il n'a
rien à dire la vraie c'est brutal qu'il
se taise d'autres ont à dire et qu'il
parle
[Musique]
refaire les lions ce soir nous rappeler
les rangers ne diront pas
elle est marocaine elle s'appelle amina
alaoui ses convictions il les exprime à
travers son art le chant arabo andalou
[Musique]
m
un chant millénaire source d'inspiration
des troubadours de la provence
allez
les
en
[Musique]
oh
au
en
[Musique]
fourche vieilles lunes des cités hlm
poussé au milieu des champs a à peine un
kilomètre du centre ville un quartier
plutôt tranquille
une forte densité d'immigrés marocains
algériens harkis qu'on croyait bien
intégrés et pourtant il ya des
communautés
les routes
quel type de problème
on vous regarde méchant ça pousse ouais
pour nous ce qui nous concerne nous
regardent méchant surtout parce que vous
êtes tous les deux mois moi je suis
penser et à l'algérienne je le dis
franchement ouvertement
mais on s'en balance maintenant ça fait
ça fait près ça fait quatre ans qu'on
est ensemble donc on a l'habitude
maintenant on s'en fout c'est nous qu'on
glisse c'est pas on vit pas pour les
autres
houria et fabrice quatre ans de vie
commune dont trois à fourche vieille il
est apprenti chauffeur routier elle fait
des ménages en attendant concert de sa
dette vous allez y aller on n'a pas les
moyens pour notre place mais j'y serais
bien allé j'aime bien voir l'aide
est créée il y avait beaucoup de gens
qui vont y avait des gens d'ici oui
comme la cité je sais pas
à
c il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui sont
d'argent quoi pourquoi ce billet de
concert
une cité rishon
on est loin pourtant des poussées de
fièvre de la banlieue parisienne loin
aussi du péril islamiste
dans la cité écrasée sous la chaleur
balayé par le mistral la chose la mieux
partagée c'est l'ennui
ne reste que la télé celle qui
colportent misère et malheurs du monde
celle qui débite violence et aident à se
demander si cela ne va pas finir par
débouler un jour chez soi scène de la
vie quotidienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou la fosse à côté pour eux et il faut
ne pas le loyer ils ont des voitures des
mercedes et des camionnettes et sur nos
côtes et vous pouvez regarder c'est tout
pareil dans la délinquance ici l'été n'a
orange et déjà plus des clandestins des
braves
parce que pourquoi honda parce que
parce que leurs riches ont quand même
apple hervé c'est pas merveilleux moi je
les connais pas
personnellement
mon âge je n'aurais pas voté pour mais
c'est pas pour ça que ça arrange les
choses
c'est lui comme les autres ils peuvent
plus rien faire
voilà
ma mère
et ma nature
il faudra l'intervention d'un adulte
d'un des sages de la cité pour que le
calme revienne en
[Applaudissements]
douce mans aujourd'hui
c'est pas avec la poste contre 6 avec la
gentillesse
donc en prêt
et
puis tu veux caresse ou à l'est
mais tout le monde n'a pas tiré les
leçons de l'histoire
c'est ici que jacques bompard a fait son
élection en recueillant plus de 40% des
suffrages au deuxième tour pendant la
campagne il est souvent venu il a
beaucoup promis
nous avait quand même beaucoup voté pour
le front national
[Musique]
les gens le disent facilement
travail pour nous parce qu'on trouve pas
de travail
je crois que la fin c'est foutu mais là
on se dit
c'est pas bon du tout et je crois que
c'était un peu bien mais maintenant
ça commence à se dégrader et je sais pas
il ya beaucoup de gens ils ont peur mais
lang tv ce que vous croyez que le front
national c'est quelque chose s'est passé
va lui les sorties mais il a pas l'air
de bouger beaucoup non plus
qui est le fun ce qu'il ya derrière ces
idées
enfin il faudrait qu'il fait un peu de
bruit quand même aujourd'hui on peut se
permettre de dire des choses qu'on
connaissait pas bah oui parce qu'avant
il y en avait quand même - même si on le
pensait on n'osait pas dire mais moi je
m'en fous pas mal mais avant je ne suis
pas comme ça moi j'étais en moselle
jettera j'ai côtoyé des gens comme ça
mais c'était pas le même cas avec ici
mais vous vous sentez un peu plus libre
de vous exprimer maintenant qu'il est
parce que je suis sur les nerfs mois au
moins moi j'ai trim tous les jours
croyant pas normal
pas normal du tout
voilà peut-être un arabe dirais la même
chose d'être un art est
durable heureux ici et il faut pas
croire et ciseaux les allocations ne
saisissant pas les allocations
qui voient leur aide je me fais de sa
femme par mois pour vivre
c'est pas que je déteste mais y en a
trop qui travaillent pas et n'ont
ramassé le chômage c'est pour chercher
un emploi
vous cherchez un emploi
mais vous voulez un emploi plus facile
ou ne pas
s'attendre à des bureaux par exemple
regarder mon père d'alléchants pourtant
ouais mais pour lui il travaille pas
dans les champs
je vais chercher moi je vais quand même
pas le travail de
management que les français qui galèrent
les arabes gaillard scott prochains mois
l'emploi et le travail de la cei est
dissoute vous vous restez chez vous
jusqu'à qu'on voit maintenant l'emploi
et
chacun essaiera de convaincre l'autre
sans que jamais le ton ne monte sans que
jamais le dialogue ne soit rompu
pourtant dans la communauté maghrébine
certains nous avouerons ne plus oser
aller en ville par crainte d'être
montrés du doigt le nouveau maire croit
tjrs être aux quelque chose
pendant les événements google sans rien
faire sans rien faire tout d'un coup on
n'a plus vu d'étranges et on en a plus y
en ait plus plus du tout
rien n'avait été fait rien mais il y
avait un contexte
appelez le congolais sentimentale
politique qui faisait que et
[Musique]
les étrangers étaient ceux santé
franchement
ce que je veux dire c'est que les
d'abord le fait que ce soit une mais une
muni d'une majorité menée par un élu du
front national prouve bien que les
français les orangeois voulu marquer
qu'eux il fallait pas dépasser certaines
bornes certaines limites et que les
étrangers ont compris aussi qu'il
fallait pas dépasser certaines limites
et cela suffit à
cela suffit enfin
de sécurité de la ville et du pays et
vous ne réglez aucun problème à rester
chez eux aussi que régler les problèmes
s'est entraîné l'augmentation de
l'insécurité l'augmentation des crimes
pour diminuer les sécurités diminuer les
crimes par tellement il ya une
diminution des crimes je considère que
j'ai déjà contribué à régler le problème
je n'ai pas complètement réglé mais
c'est pas de ma compétence je passe la
prétention vous croyez en plus avoir
apporté la preuve que immigration et
insécurité aller de faire un message
vous savez
s'il ya quelqu'un qui veut débattre avec
moi de ce dossier après quand
le rôle de justicier n'est pas pour
déplaire à jacques bompard depuis son
installation à orange il ya trente ans
il a vu défiler pas mal doran joie dans
son cabinet de dentiste et s'il ne
pratique plus aujourd'hui il reste un os
table reconnu
depuis des années ils tissent habilement
sa toile en centre ville comme dans les
cités
ne fait-il pas l'un des 33 députés font
national en 86 aujourd'hui il jure qu
orange ne sera pas le laboratoire de la
gestion front national
municipal n'est pas une affaire
d'étiquette politique je n'ai pas
compétence à faire la loi j'ai seulement
compétences à l'appliquer et c'est
jean marie le pen a dit quand même que
c'est bien le programme du front
national
cliquez dans les villes
d'abord le club d'abord je dois dire
que l'équipe que je mène est une équipe
largement ouverte que je sais
aujourd'hui que nous nous sommes tous
engagés à oublier nos étiquettes
politiques respectives lorsque nous
rentrions au conseil municipal et que je
me suis pour ma part engagé comme les
autres
par écrit ça vous arrange pas d'une
certaine manière ça
voilà à demi avoué ce qui pourrait bien
être la stratégie du parti de jean marie
le pen
normaliser banalisée l'élection d'un
maire front national comme ce fut le cas
à orange mais aussi à toulon ou à
marignane offrir l'image d'une gestion
lice ne plus effrayer l'électeur quitte
à ne pas appliquer immédiatement et à la
lettre le programme du
jacques bompard ou cheval de troie à la
conquête d'un pouvoir plus large encore
sans doute d'ailleurs le maire d'orange
ne parle déjà plus de préférence
nationale comme jean marie le pen il
préfère les termes plus anodin est plus
floue de préférence orangeoise et s'il
affiche un apolitisme de façade il se
présente aussi comme un parfait
démocrate n'hésitant pas à jouer la
carte du populisme en mettant à la
disposition des habitants des cahiers de
doléances nous on a regardé trop que ça
marche très bien
ça marche il ya des suggestions
il ya des suggestions intéressantes dans
quels domaines par exemple tous les
domaines tous les domaines
nous nous les avons passé en revue
places de parking problèmes de voirie
avec la sécurité les préoccupations de
la vie quotidienne ont constitué le
fonds de commerce électoral de jacques
bompard mais jacques bompard a lui-même
beaucoup écrit nous nous sommes rendus à
la bibliothèque municipale à
l'improviste
on est savoir si vous avez
livre dont je compare ici il
un
bouquin qui traitait quoi les femmes les
femmes vous êtes sûr qu'il n'est pas ici
apparemment bien peu d'orange ou à
connaissent la littérature de leur
nouveau maire
[Musique]
j'avais depuis longtemps cela ouais cet
ouvrage
avant l'élection de monsieur bah il
sortait beaucoup
une idée
je crois avoir bien
d'autres titres que
se livrent un disponibles à la
bibliothèque
nous l'avons retrouvé à orange écrit en
1991 à quatre mains avec son épouse
marie-claude voyage autour de la femme
c'est son titre révèle un tout autre
monsieur bompard
morceaux choisis
face à la gigantesque explosion
démographique des pays sous développés
la dénatalité européenne créé
littéralement un appel à l'invasion des
peuples étrangers ou colonisation
d'ailleurs encouragé par les partis
politiques institutionnels
si cette politique se perpétue qui
demain assurera la sécurité des femmes
âgées
rappelons pour mémoire toutes les séries
de meurtres qui ont frappé les personnes
âgées tels ceux commis en 1987 il est
indispensable aussi bien pour l'avenir
immédiat que lointain de maintenir notre
substrat ethnique aussi homogène que
possible la france jacques bompard ne
l'envisagent que blanche et chrétienne
l'ancien activistes de l'oas et militant
du groupuscule ultra violent en occident
a aussi l'obsession du complot une caste
international de grands financiers et
d'hommes politiques a défini un
programme et une stratégie ayant pour
but de les conduire à la conquête du
pouvoir mondial ces individus se
répartissent un peu partout sur la
planète
le premier stade de cette conquête
mondiale passe par l'infiltration de
diverses institutions nationales cette
première phase est déjà largement
commencé ses cibles désignées les francs
maçons et les hommes politiques
progressistes comme raymond barre ou
michel rocard jacques bompard dénoncent
aussi pèle-mêle l'avortement la
décadence de l'art contemporain et même
les restaurants mcdonald's
la civilisation occidentale ne s'est
jamais trouvée en aussi graves périls
qu'aujourd'hui même si elle évite le
suicide par la guerre elle s'achemine
vers la dégénérescence grâce à la
stérilité des groupes humains les plus
forts et les plus intelligents
pour étayer sa thèse monsieur le maire
d'orange n'hésitez pas à l'époque a
appelé à la rescousse alexis carrel
dignitaires du régime pétainiste et
grand admirateur de mussolini
[Musique]
les nuits de la méditerranée est tombé
sur orange
le groupe corse i muvrini donne le ton
ce concert ce sera une main tendue vers
l'eau notre conscience notre coeur avait
envie d'être là et je crois que il faut
savoir il faut savoir avancer là où il y
a où il ya incompréhension là où il y as
intolérance il faut que d'autres gestes
d'autres actes d'autres signes
apparaissent on ne pas que les distances
se creuse pour ne pas que les hommes ces
gars pour ne pas que des comportements
ans en pire les uns et par les autres
donc avançons on ne résiste pas un seul
jour par an on résiste tous les jours
[Musique]
nous avons retrouvé ça brille c'est
horreya au pied du théâtre antique comme
prévu il était venu avec des amis de la
cité de fourche vieille se frottèrent à
la fête sans pouvoir se mêler la place
août et 180 francs
[Musique]
et ce soir leurs propos avaient un goût
amer comme si ce qui se passait à orange
de les concerner plus vraiment
comment voulez vous
moi je ne vois pas comment je pourrais
vexé
nous on est la base société pas d'argent
peut pas résister ceux qui ont de
l'argent eux ils peuvent ils ont
l'argent courte
pour aller aux concerts par exemple
voilà et puis pour
savoir ce qu'ils veulent les niveaux
social pour nous tous là-bas société ce
ne sont pas d'argent on ne peut pas
avoir ce qu'on veut
ce qu'on aimerait
jeune
fabrice et oriane n'ont pas attendu la
fin du concert ils sont repartis à pied
vers fourche vieille et cette nuit là le
mistral a eu beau souffler les notes de
musique ne sont pas parvenus jusqu'à
leur cité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]